unser experte für hygiene vor einem
klaus dieter zastrow
sagen sie uns jetzt sprechen wir hier
vor allem über die kommune alleine also
diese beschränkungen dann darf nur 15
kilometer von seiner meldeadresse weit
sich entfernen wie sinnhaft ich glauben
sie ist das um die aktuellen kohona
zahlen zu senken vor allem die
ansteckung natürlich ja ehrlich gesagt
ich glaube überhaupt nicht dass er in
haft ist und habe auch den eindruck
immer mehr und auch gewonnen und
bestätigt durch literaturrecherchen das
bisher eigentlich überhaupt nichts
wissenschaftlich wirklich bestätigt ist
am anfang haben wir sind von den
wissenschaftlern gut beraten und und die
politik hört auch darauf wenn man da mal
ihnen ein guckt man kann da gar nichts
finden
und genauso wenig sind die 15 kilometer
man könnte auch sagen acht oder zehn mit
anderen worten es ist gewürfelt und ob
das wirklich etwas bringt das wage ich
sogar zu bezweifeln es soll ja vor allem
haben die bilder gesehen am wochenende
es hat geschneit wollten viele raus und
sind natürlich in orte gefahren in denen
sie selber gar nicht leben und haben zu
chaos zu menschenansammlungen
dagegen könnte das ganze jahr doch
helfen oder nicht ja das wäre gut für
die verkehrspolizei aber die korona lage
würde das überhaupt nicht verändern die
leute winterspaziergang schlitten
gefahren diese ziele nicht mit 20 mann
auf einem schlitten und vielleicht noch
20 fremde und wenn die im stau stehen ja
haben sie eben pech gehabt aber alkohol
wackelt das überhaupt nicht
beziehungsweise auch da
auf dem parkplatz wird auch nicht
übertragen die leute stehen ja alle
nicht in bündeln
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren